New York City is getting ready for its
annual New Year's Eve celebration in
Times Square as we get set to ring in
2020 we're also looking back at the
legacy of the 2010s a decade of
political and technological change in
the past ten years same-sex marriage
became legal nationwide and some states
legalized recreational marijuana we saw
a return of Star Wars fever wait return
fevers been around since 1977
we saw mistakes at the Oscars lady go oh
I don't know I heard Lady Gaga's meat
dress and so much more
we asked five journalists and experts
how they think the 2010s will be
remembered the 2010 really was the
decade where we flipped the table on the
status quo a truly magical and
revolutionary product today we can
change the world
we started this decade with Barack Obama
so help you God
so help me God in many ways where we're
at started with Barack Obama because the
American voters wanted something totally
different and it just became more and
more different throughout the decade
[Applause]
when you look back at the 2010 I don't
know how you don't remember Donald Trump
we are building a wall he is a sick
puppy he's the greatest show on earth
whether you like it or not and 2010 was
about reality TV shows we ended the
decade with a reality TV show
we started the decade with an economic
crisis and we finished it with an
existential crisis everything that
happened in the 2010s was rooted in this
enormous ly disruptive and frightening
collapse of the economy this was the
dow's worst one-day point drops the Dow
Jones average dropping 213 points it
ripped apart a bunch of institutions and
norms and now we're kind of asking
ourselves what kind of a world do we
want the 2010 will be remembered as the
decade when the meter movement went
global
it felt like all of the sudden this
issue which had a history of lack of
accountability suddenly had a new sense
that there could be consequences for
this kind of behavior time is up we are
no longer going to be harassed I'm
responsible for what happens here the
moment that might have defined the arc
of the 2010s in tech it's Mark
Zuckerberg testifying after the
Cambridge analytical scandal and it was
my mistake and I'm sorry when we go from
a moment of innovation Amazon Alexa
Alexa House traffic news uber Instagram
the real reckoning about the
consequences of tactic stop apologizing
let's make the change your User
Agreement sucks what's extraordinary
about some of these hashtag movements is
that they weren't just a name
people actually marched people went out
into the streets people protested didn't
walk out I think about when I was first
getting into politics when I was in my
early teens and I felt like as a young
person you were sort of meant to be
patted on the head and and isn't this
nice and I feel like now there's really
a space the world is waking up and
change is coming whether you like it or
not and once again we witness history
unfold the Emmy goes to Billy Porter
this whole decade of transformation
especially in entertainment in film is
that while we still have a very long way
to go there's so much that's promising
mahalo Ali became the first Muslim actor
to win an Academy Award siharan Bigelow
the first woman to win Best Director
Laverne Cox the first openly transgender
woman ever nominated for an acting Emmy
some of these I made my own I don't
think that you can understate the impact
of seeing some of these firsts coming in
entertainment yeah Ava Duvernay running
her own studio headlining movies like
crazy rich Asians
in a black panther it actually moved the
needle on what it meant to have a
predominantly black cast in the Marvel
Universe
[Music]
Hamilton is a breathtaking body over
there what do you think you are
Gary Antoinette decadent TV was just I
mean explosive because we can stream
them whenever we want we're able to sort
of consume much more complex culture
whenever we want on our own time and it
led to the creation of amazing
television obvious that is nothing was
about to happen until something happened
[Music]
this was the decade that queen bee's
fiance ascended to her throne when you
think about the album lemonade for
example which was all about black pride
and self-worth her performance at
Coachella was so amazing that they
renamed it beige Ella I mean she ran
away with a decade heads down
that's down the right-field line into
the corner the sports moment of the
decade absolutely has to be the
Washington Nationals winning the World
Series three two I'm a huge Nationals
fan so I'm a little bit biased Republic
it was just a a great uplifting story at
a time that America needed more than
ever before terrible song but a great
rallying cry you still do it first now
[Music]
you know I can't tell you what the 2020s
will be defined by but I can tell you
this we live in an era where it just
feels like every bill is coming due at
once the big debates about health care
Joe's plan essentially retained the
status quo that's not true about the
environment but I think basically nobody
thinks that the system is really fair
anymore so it just feels like we're
living not only through one reckoning
but a kind of cascade of reckonings I'm
really excited about space exploration
the future of space exploration is
something really exciting to look
forward to in the 2020s
[Music]
I really am kind of curious what's gonna
happen with that Tesla truck I think it
looks like something out of the Jetsons
well here we go again this is a great
time to be alive and the next decade is
going to be crazy
I want my flying car want my flying car
that's everybody up in the air streets
and sidewalks empty I'm down with that
because you'll stay on the street I'll
stay on the streets go for a stroll
always oh my gosh reflective 10 years
the last 10 years yeah and to try to
remember what stands out to you most and
we were talking about the the Netflix
change of everything that we talked
about obviously in there the way we
consume media you know will stand out
for me this year tell me at the same
time same place
you